und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend ihnen wir beginnen mit einem
Polizeieinsatz der in die Geschichte des
Sommerlochs eingehen dürfte 200 Beamte
Hubschrauber Drohnen Wärmebildkameras
und für die Anwohner im Süden Berlins
und dem angrenzenden Brandenburg eine
unruhige Nacht der Ungewissheit wie eine
Zeitung schrieb die Warnung der Behörden
verlassen sie die Wohnung nicht es werde
eine streunende Löwin gesucht
heute ist die Welt eine andere die
Polizei gibt Entwarnung man könne sagte
örtliche Bürgermeister mit ziemlicher
Sicherheit davon ausgehen dass das Tier
Zitat gen-
internationale Schlagzeilen hat die
Sache da längst gemacht und das war
nicht das erste Mal dass der Löwe los
ist Christian
Großalarm in kleinen Magnum alles ist am
Rande der Hauptstadt im Einsatz
Hubschrauber Hundertschaften Drohnen
Panzerfahrzeuge Wärmebildkameras wird
hier Experten Tierärzte Spurenleser
statt Jäger und jede Menge Reporter
der Löw ist los
dieser schreckensruf verbreitete sich
einem Lauffeuer gleich
Kinderwagen fielen um und ergossen ihren
schreienden Inhalt auf die Wege
ältere Damen die sonst nur mühsam
einherschluchten
liefen plötzlich das ist eine Freude war
die lästerallee war wie leer gefegt und
nur
ängstliche Kellner saßen hoch oben in
die Zweigen der Bäume
der Löwe ist los
diese acht Sekunden lösten Großalarm aus
eine Löwen soll zu sehen sein die
Polizei schätzte das Video als echt ein
es sind verwackelte Handybilder eines
19-Jährigen der sie in seiner
Freundesgruppe teilt wenig später gehen
die vermeintlichen raubtierbilder viral
die Nachricht verbreitet sich weltweit
ein britisches Boulevard Titel Garde
Beast of Berlin
nach erster Sichtung sind wir von einer
Ernsthaftigkeit ausgegangen also dass es
sich tatsächlich um ein Wildtier handelt
und entsprechend haben wir sofortige
Suchmaßnahmen und Maßnahmen zum Schutz
der Bevölkerung
eingeleitet doch es gibt keinerlei
Spuren und Beweise wieder Blut Haare Kot
oder putenabdrücke nach 30 Stunden
daueraufregung und zahlreichen
Sondersendungen gibt der Bürgermeister
von kleinen mach nur an Mittag kleinlot
Entwarnung es war keine Löwen es war ein
brandenburgisches Wildschwein
die teuerste Safari aller Zeiten
entpuppt sich als Fehlalarm OP
Panikmacher mit Tieren verkauft sich
halt gut das Erleben war jetzt in vier
in verschiedensten Bereichen das
natürlich ein Grundproblem nicht als
empfindet dann doch eben eine sehr
starke Hysterisierung der ganzen
Geschehnisse statt und dann bis zu
zahllosen Verhaltenstipps die ich jetzt
gelesen habe wie man sich bei einem
Angesicht eines Löwen auf dem Waldweg zu
verhalten hat das alles sind Dinge die
an der Stelle nicht hilfreich sind die
Löwen von kleinen mach nur eine perfekte
sommerloch-geschichte Folge von
Sensationsgier und Jagd nach Klickzahlen
im tiktok Zeitalter aber mal ehrlich war
das vor 100 Jahren anders Berlin war
aufgestört wie ein Ameisenhaufen alle
telefonische schrillten mit einem Male
extra Ausgabe halte es durch das Haus
eine Löwin die ein Wildschwein ist das
Top sogar tucholskis Sommer vom
entlaufenen Löwen
wendet sich am Ende enttäuscht von
Berlin ab aber das ist eine andere
Geschichte
der Deutschen Polizeigewerkschaft der
spricht von mehreren hunderttausend Euro
kosten die an das wo besser investiert
gewesen wären
im deutschen Parlament wurde heute
gelöst die Bundestagspräsidentin als
Glücksfee und jetzt hat dieses Land
einen sogenannten Bürgerrat
160 Menschen bei deren Auswahl neben dem
Zufall auch bestimmte Quoten eine Rolle
spielten der Bürgerrat soll über ganz
konkrete Themen diskutieren dazu
Empfehlungen geben generell die
Demokratie bereichern sagen die einen
wir haben aber doch bereits einen
Bürgerrat sagen die anderen der heißt
Bundestag
was ist das also ein konkreter Weg an
Politik teil zu haben oder die
schleichende Entmachtung des Parlaments
Britta Spiekermann berichtet
kaum sind die Abgeordneten des Deutschen
Bundestages in der Sommerpause geschieht
in einem Nebengebäude des Parlaments
etwas Eigenartiges ich begrüße Sie alle
ganz herzlich hier im Saal und auch im
Livestream zur bürgerlotterie zur
bürgerlotterie des bürgerrats Ernährung
Bundestagspräsidentin Bars zieht drei
Zahlen Schlusspunkt eines mehrstufigen
Auswahlverfahrens nach dem
Zufallsprinzip diese geloste
Zahlenkombination steht für einen
Bürgerrat
160 deutsche querbeet ausgewählt nach
Alter Geschlecht Bildung stand Region
zwei hatten sich besondere Hoffnungen
gemacht dabei zu sein waren extra
angereist möchte halt darauf hinwirken
dass seit alle Bevölkerungsschichten die
Möglichkeit haben sich gesund
biologisch ökologisch wertvoll
nachhaltig ernähren können auch halten
welche mit kleinen Einkommen oder
Sozialhilfeempfänger ich leite zum
Beispiel eine Kita
da war das gerade Thema
da haben wir mit den Elternbeiräten
zusammengesessen und genau überlegt wie
können wir
Ernährung im Wandel in Zukunft gestalten
die ampelregierung hatte sich in ihr
Aufgabenheft geschrieben Bürgerrechte zu
bilden wohl gegen Politik Verdrossenheit
wohl gegen dieses die da oben die da
unten der Bundestag werde sich mit den
Ergebnissen befassen wird versprochen
mehr nicht unsere parlamentarische
Demokratie braucht frische Ansätze um
das Vertrauen in die etablierten
Institutionen zu stärken diese
Meinungsvielfalt bereichert die
Demokratie und verschafft vor allen
Dingen denen eine Stimme die wir immer
so als stille Mehrheit bezeichnen
bürgerräte sein allerdings keine
nebenparlament am Ende entscheide stets
der Bundestag der ist mit über 700
Abgeordneten ausgestattet die im besten
Fall bestens rückekoppelt sind mit ihren
Wahlkreisen
unserer Gegenwind für den Bürgerrat von
der Opposition
Abgeordnete vertreten Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und zwar legitimiert durch Wahlen
das heißt wir brauchen kein
alibi-parlament das durch das Los
zusammengewürfelt ist wir haben uns
immer eingesetzt für mehr
Bürgerbeteiligung aber echte
Bürgerbeteiligung beispielsweise durch
direkte Volksabstimmung auch auf
Bundesebene da fehlen sie ja
bundesweite bürgerräte gab es bereits in
Hochglanz Werbespots präsentiert die
Themen Demokratie Deutschlands Rolle in
der Welt oder das Klima offiziell gelobt
aber folgenlos jetzt der erste durch das
Parlament eingesetzte Bürgerrat aber wir
brauchen dort mehr Verbindlichkeit und
das ist natürlich nur an den Symptomen
herum Doktoren sondern wir haben das
können wir konzentrieren eine wirkliche
Krise der Demokratie der Bürgerrat als
Impulsgeber in schweren Zeiten oder doch
nur ein Feigenblatt zu Geschichte gehört
auch ausgerechnet auf sie fällt das Los
nicht über das Thema Ernährung im Wandel
werden andere beraten
so jetzt seine erste
Nachrichtenübersicht an diesem Freitag
von Diana
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium stockt das
Budget für die Kaufprämie von
Elektroautos auf 400 Millionen Euro
werden zusätzlich zur Verfügung gestellt
das soll laut Ministerium Planbarkeit
und Sicherheit für Verbraucher und
Wirtschaft bringen bisher war der
Fördertopf auf 2,1 Milliarden Euro
gedeckelt das Anfang Juli wurden davon
allerdings bereits 1,72 Milliarden
ausgezahlt und es gilt das Prinzip ist
die Summe ausgeschöpft gehen
Antragsteller leer aus
im nächsten Jahr finden in den USA die
Präsidentschaftswahlen statt und nun ist
klar mitten im Wahlkampf wird der
Prozess gegen den früheren
US-Präsidenten Trump in der
dokumentenaffäre stattfinden die
zuständige Richterin nannte den 20 Mai
2024 als ersten Verhandlungstermin Trump
war im Juni auf Bundesebene angeklagt
worden ihm wird vorgeworfen streng
geheime Regierungsdokumente in seinem
Privatanwesen in Mara Lago aufbewahrt zu
haben einer Verurteilung droht dem
Ex-Präsidenten eine lange Haftstrafe er
selbst plädierte vor Gericht auf nicht
schuldig
UN-Generalsekretär gut herrisch hat eine
neue Agenda für Frieden vorgestellt
dabei sprach er von den größten
geopolitischen Spannungen zwischen
Großmächten seit Jahrzehnten in dem
Strategiepapier rekutärisch unter
anderem eine Reform der
UN-Friedensmissionen an Ziel müssten
flexible
anpassungsfähige blauhelm Einsätze mit
exit Strategien sein
kurz vor einer wichtigen Abstimmung über
die umstrittene Justizreform in Israel
steigt der Druck von der Straße in der
Nacht zum Freitag kam es erneut zu
Protesten und Ausschreitungen zuvor
hatte Ministerpräsident netan Yahoo die
Pläne der Regierung verteidigt tausende
Israelis haben sich mittlerweile einen
Protestmarsch von Tel Aviv nach
Jerusalem angeschlossen am Samstag soll
er vor dem Parlament enden
das Schwarze Meer wird zunehmend zu
einem Brennpunkt des russischen Krieges
gegen die Ukraine und das hat Folgen die
weit über die Ukraine hinausreichen
russland hat wieder die Hafenstadt
Odessa angegriffen wieder speziell Silos
für Getreide dort getroffen und die
russische Marine übt mit Anti
schiffsraketen jedes Schiff das
ukrainische Häfen anlaufe sei ein
potentielles Ziel also deshalb berichtet
es hätte ein gutes Jahr werden können
für die Getreide Bauern in der Ukraine
die Ähren sind prall das Wetter gut noch
letzten Samstag war Bauer Russland
voller Optimismus heute klingen seine
Worte wie aus einer anderen Welt
dabei ist noch keine ganze Woche
verstrichen
ich denke dass der getreidekorridor
weiter funktionieren und offen bleiben
wird
es ist doch so wenn die Ukraine kein
Getreide verkaufen kann dann wird es
eine Ernährungskrise in der Welt geben
wir sind kein so großes Land aber wir
ernähren dafür viele Länder
die Getreide lkw-rollen noch als
Russland das Getreide Abkommen beendet
und die Ukraine dafür wird den Export
über das Schwarze Meer vorzuführen auch
ohne russische Beteiligung diese
Hoffnung stirbt noch in derselben Nacht
seit vier Tagen beschießt Russland die
helfen um und deshalb mit
Marschflugkörpern ein Beladen der
Schiffe ist so schlichtweg unmöglich zu
dem bezeichnet Russland alle Schiffe die
ukrainische Häfen ansteuern als
mögliches militärisches Ziel die Drogen
wirkt
ein Schiff ist mehr in Richtung Ukraine
ausgelaufen oder hat ukrainische Häfen
verlassen weil die Drohungen des Feindes
Schiffe zu zerstören in Kraft gesetzt
sind
im Gegenzug verbietet die Ukraine für
Schiffe die Anfahrt russisch
kontrollierte Häfen insbesondere immer
so viel mehr
aus welcher Distanz in welchem Gebiet
und auf welche Art und Weise es wird
eine Überraschung wir haben öffentlich
bekannt gegeben auch gegenüber
ausländischen schiffseigentümern dass
wir offen und ehrlich jeden angreifen
der Russlands Terrorismus unterstützt
und diese Bekanntmachung ist fair
der Ukraine bleibt noch ein Seeweg durch
rumänische Gewässer über den Donauhafen
in Israel das ist teuer aber immerhin
kann die Ukraine schon 60% ihrer
Getreideexporte über Alternativrouten
zum Schwarzen Meer transportieren und es
ist am Ende dieser Woche die einzige
Hoffnung der Bauern ihre Ernte zu
verkaufen
die Parteien streiten darüber wie eine
klimafreundliche Transformation der
Wirtschaft gelingen kann umfragen sagen
einen politischen Rechtsruck voraus es
geht dabei aber nicht um Deutschland
sondern um ein Land das viele Deutsche
als zweite heimatadoptiert haben
zumindest in Urlaubszeiten dessen
Politik bei uns aber eher wenig beachtet
wird die Spanierinnen und Spanier wählen
am Sonntag und es sieht nach
Machtwechsel aus zwischen la corunia und
Cadiz Anna Warsberg berichtet
vor der Parlamentswahl werben die
Konservativen hier um die letzten
stimmen sie ziehen von Laden zu Laden
fragen wie es geht und kaufen
Haushaltsartikel brauchst du dreieinhalb
oder zweieinhalb Meter Kabel 2,5
der Generalsekretär aus Madrid will
Volksnähe zeigen seine Partei die PP
will die linke Regierung von Petrus
Sanchez ablösen und trifft hier auf
viele Menschen die das begrüßen würden
ich hoffe dass Sie damit beginnen die
Wahrheit zu sagen und dass es einen
ernsthaften Ansatz geben wird und nicht
mit Leuten in der Regierung wie sie
Petrus Sanchez hatte mit diesen
verrückten Mädchen von polemos in
Sanchez Minderheitsregierung sind mehr
als die Hälfte Ministerinnen das
Kabinett aus Sozialisten und
Linkspopulisten hat unter anderem
Frauenrechte gestärkt und ein neues
transgendergesetz verabschiedet die
Inflation liegt inzwischen bei unter 2%
in Spanien besser als in vielen anderen
EU-Ländern trotzdem liegt Sanchez in
vielen Umfragen finden
Zeitpunkt und das Ergebnis dieses
Wahlkampfes sind klar die Rechten haben
ihre Lügen verbreitet und wir kriegen
unser Comeback
den Zeitpunkt der Wahl hat der
Amtsinhaber vorgezogen um seine
bröckelnde Macht zu sichern seit dieser
Entscheidung ist der Wahlkampf weniger
von Inhalten als davon geprägt das links
und rechts sich gegenseitig attackieren
Sanchez kannte keine Grenzen bei der
Niedertracht seines Wahlkampfs sie haben
uns beschimpft gegen uns intrigiert und
uns bedroht
um die Regierung zu übernehmen könnten
die Konservativen auf die extremen
Rechten VOX als Partner angewiesen sein
die Positionen der Partei sind
nationalistisch EU kritisch und
zuwanderungsfeindlich
unsere Viertel verwahrlosen immer weiter
wegen der illegalen Einwanderung und
wegen des Drogenhandels
lange dachte man in Spanien hätten
Rechtspopulisten keine Chance jetzt
regiert VOX bereits in mehreren
autonomen Regionen mit der Volkspartei
PP zusammen
wir sehen das dort die Bürgerrechte
sexueller minder
Community weniger anerkannt werden oder
auch das bestimmte Räte wie umwelträte
zum Beispiel abgeschafft werden
bei der Wahlkampfveranstaltung im
Madrider vor Ort sagen ist die
Konservativen nicht direkt aber sie
schließen es auch nicht aus mit den
extremen Rechten im Zweifel eine
Regierungskoalition zu bilden
ja Sonntag zur heute-journalzeit
erwarten wir erste Ergebnisse aus
Spanien jetzt noch mal hier du Hanna auf
deutsch schauen wir auf einen wichtigen
Industriezweig in Deutschland bei dem es
gerade alles andere als rund läuft der
Chemiebranche brechen die Aufträge Weg
für 2023 wird eine Rückgang der
Produktion von 8% erwartet fragen wir
nach bei Frank Bethmann wie sind diese
Zahlen einzuordnen ja sie sind durchaus
ernst zu nehmen schließe dich ist die
Chemie so etwas wie ein früh Indikator
für die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung sie
beliefert die Industrie mit Farben
Lacken Chemikalien und Kunststoffen und
wenn da die Nachfrage zurückgeht dann
lässt das nichts Gutes erahnen der
branchenverwand VCI zeichnete da heute
ein düsteres Bild nicht nur die
Produktion wird weiter zurückgefahren
sondern damit werden auch die Branchen
Umsätze drastisch einbrechen von zuvor
bereits schwachprognostizierten -7 auf
-14% in diesem Jahr also da muss man
drumherum reden in der Chemie und
Pharma-Branche stehen die Zeichen auf
Krise welche Konsequenzen könnte diese
Entwicklung denn jetzt mit sich bringen
ja aus der Chemieindustrie hatte es
letztes Jahr bereits eine Reihe von
Gewinnwarnungen gegeben und
vci-präsident Markus Steilmann nahm da
heute kein Blatt vor dem Mund die
Nachfrage nimmt ab die Zahlen sind rot
die Produktionskosten am Standort
Deutschland nicht wettbewerbsfähig die
Chemieproduktion bekanntermaßen ja sehr
energieintensiv Konzerne wie BASF haben
daher angekündigt eben wegen jener hohen
Produktionskosten verstärkt im Ausland
zu investieren etwa in China kurz um
auch die Chemie ruft nach dem Staat wird
für einen subventionierten
industriestrompreis die ampelregierung
aber zögert noch vielen Dank für diese
Einschätzung
die Europäische Arzneimittelbehörde hat
grünes Licht für die Zulassung eines
Impfstoffes gegen dass er es Virus
gegeben das vor allem bei Säuglingen zu
tödlichen Atemwegserkrankungen führen
kann das Mittel ist der erste Impfstoff
der auch Babys gegen das RSV schweres
schützen kann indem die Mutter während
der Schwangerschaft geimpft wird im
vergangenen Winter waren wegen einer
rsv-welle viele Kinderkliniken
überlastet
im vergangenen Jahr sind in Deutschland
deutlich weniger Kinder zur Welt
gekommen wieder Statistische Bundesamt
meldet Sankt die Geburtenrate nach dem
Babyboom Jahr 2021 um sieben Prozent auf
fast
739.000 Kinder rechnerisch bekommt eine
Frau hierzulande damit 1,46 Kinder das
ist der niedrigste Stand seit zehn
Jahren
Tag zwei der Frauenfußball-WM in
Australien und Neuseeland lief für die
Kanadierinnen anders als erhofft im
Spiel gegen Nigeria blieb es beim 0:0
die Schweiz konnte sich hingegen mit
einem 2:0 über einen erfolgreichen
wm-auftrag gegen die Philippinen freuen
und die Top Favoritinnen aus Spanien
trafen auf Costa Rica dort vielen alle
Tore in nur sechs Minuten entstand drei
zu null
so haben die meisten von uns das
Synchronschwimmen vor Augen Akrobatik
und Rhythmus wasserfeste Schminke und
Frisuren die jeder Welle trotzen es ist
eine unterschätzte und oft belächelte
Sportart eine die anstrengt wie alle
nachfüllen können den im Schwimmbad
unter Wasser schnell die Luft weg bleibt
selbst wenn sie keine aufwändigen
Figuren tanzen es war lange auch ein
Sport ohne Männer jetzt müssen wir neu
denken dieser Jani
sieben Frauen ein Mann und eine
WM-Premiere im Synchronschwimmen sind
Männer erst seit neuestem überhaupt bei
Teamwettkämpfen zugelassen
in Japan erreichten die Deutschen auf
Anhieb das Finale landeten auf Platz 9
Friedhof Seidel ist der einzige deutsche
Synchronschwimmer bei der WM in Fukuoka
und auch sonst in dieser Sportart ein
seltenes Exemplar ja kann man so sagen
also bisher gibt es nur sehr wenige
Männer in Deutschland machen und ich
hoffe das ändert sich in naher Zukunft
ursprünglich war er Wasserspringer
wechselte erst vor zwei Jahren zum
Synchronschwimmen
Training in Berlin mit seiner
duett-partnerin Michelle Zimmer sie ist
dabei seit sie sechs Jahre alt ist da
hat Seidel auch als Leistungssportler
einiges nachzuholen dadurch dass das
Wasser springen sehr kurzweiliger Sport
war habe ich aktuell echt noch mit der
Kondition zu kämpfen das ist die Prinz
über Wasser und da dann die Luft
anzuhalten die Ruhe zu bewahren und
trotzdem die Präzision zu behalten in
den Übungen und Elementen die wir
Performance
zu schaffen macht
Akrobatik unter Wasser ohne Bodenkontakt
im Duett durften Männer schon bei der WM
2015 mitmachen doch sie bleiben Exoten
im synchronschwimmbecken und auch
Michelle Zimmer hat erstmalig einen
schwimmpartner an ihrer Seite
er hat deutlich mehr Kraft kann mich bei
jedem Figuren
herauswerfen sage ich mal ähm aber
ansonsten ist es mittlerweile ziemlich
ähnlich
Trockenübungen um sich Abläufe
einzuprägen jede Bewegung muss stimmen
auf die Sekunde
unter Wasser Lautsprecher geben den Takt
vor oder aber die erfahrene
schwimmpartnerin
es gibt eine Person die piept unter
Wasser die macht einen Geräusch mit dem
Mund und das hört dann ja nach einer
Person und dann sehen wir
und dann zählen wir die Takte und wissen
wo wir die Bewegung drauf machen
Bewegungen die der 26-Jährige Berliner
sich neu angeeignet hat in zwei Jahren
trainierte er sich auf wm-niveau auch
wenn er ganz klein angefangen hat in
einer kindertrainingsgruppe
die kleinen Mädels waren dann auch so
wie ja warum ist er jetzt hier und am
Anfang war es natürlich auch so viel
schlechter aus als bei denen aber man
kann da natürlich auch bei den ganz
kleinen vier abgucken und lernen und das
habe ich versucht und das hat geklappt
eine starke Performance im gemischten
Duett heute in Japan den Finale Einzug
nur knapp verpasst Friedhof Seidel hofft
dass er auch Vorbild sein kann
ausnahmsweise mal für mehr Männer im
Frauensport
sie Piepen unter Wasser ich bin immer
noch komplett fasziniert unser nächstes
Thema jetzt wenn einer der mit
unzähligen Platten jahrzehntelang
Musikgeschichte prägt über sich sagt ich
habe nicht an einem einzigen Tag in
meinem Leben gearbeitet
dann hat er einiges richtig gemacht Tony
Bennett hatte Spaß an dem was er tat und
das haben die Leute gemerkt keiner der
Nachrufe auf ein langes legendäres
Entertainer leben heute kommt ohne den
Hinweis auf seinen Charme aus und auf
diese Stimme die alle Honig warm nennen
singen war für ihn alles es hat ihm
mehrere Male das Leben gerettet sagt
seine Frau jetzt ist Toni Bernet
gestorben er wurde 96 Jahre alt MRT
wissen
er berührte unsere Herzen
[Musik]
verloren Toni Bennet in seinem
berühmtesten Lied denn San Francisco
[Musik]
über sieben Jahrzehnte von den 50er
Jahren bis heute sang er und unterhielt
die Menschen geboren als Anthony Dominik
Benedetto 1926 in New York Vater
Giovanni sang mit den Kindern
italienische Volkslieder Toni wurde zu
einem der großen Interpreten
amerikanischer Musik entdeckt 1949 von
Bob
seine Stimme sandig eingängig
[Musik]
Frank Sinatra nannte ihn den vielleicht
besten Popsänger der Welt
ein Entertainer der gefiel aber der auch
in den 60er Jahren in der
Bürgerrechtsbewegung aktiv war in den
70ern Ehe und Drogenprobleme hatte bis
ich erkannte dass die Drogen nicht gut
für mich waren
Bennet erfand sich neu wurde Kult bei
den Simpsons
arbeitete mit Amy Winehouse zusammen
[Musik]
und mit Lady Gaga
mit ihr gewann er 2022 seinen letzten
von insgesamt 20 Grammys seine Frau
Susan machte öffentlich dass ihr Toni
schon seit Jahren an Alzheimer nett
okay er verlor Stück für Stück seine
Erinnerungen aber nie seinen Humor
und schon gar nicht seine Musik als er
sie hört
er einfach an zu singen über eine Stunde
lang
alles noch da
[Musik]
sein Abschiedskonzert mit Lady Gaga im
August 2021 hieß one last time ein
letztes Mal
Tony Bennett der Sänger der die Herzen
berührte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich halte Toni Bernet für den besten
Sänger im Business er bewegt mich er
bringt genau das rüber was der Komponist
sich gedacht hat und vermutlich noch ein
bisschen mehr hat Frank Sinatra gesagt
und damit verabschieden wir uns und sie
ins Wochenende ja und empfehlen Ihnen
außerdem noch unser heute journal Update
gegen 0:10 Uhr mit Christopher Wehrmann
vom gesamten Team auch den Kolleginnen
und Kollegen hier hinter den Kameras
unangenehmer Abend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter dieses Tief hier
über Deutschland das hat heute shower
teilweise mit Gewittern gebracht und das
verabschiedet sich allmählich Richtung
Polen aber die Strömung die dreht
allmählich auf Nordwest und wir sehen
hier ein neues Tief heranziehen es
bringt viele Wolken und auch Regen mit
und das kommt allmählich näher der
kommende Nacht lassen Schauer und
Gewitter vor allem im Norden allmählich
nach Blitz und Donner werden auch im
Süden weniger dann wird es trocken so
ähnlich wie ganz im Westen Deutschlands
zwei tiefsten Temperaturen dort von 7
bis 8 Grad 14 gibt's an der Nordsee und
auch 14 Grad am Oberrhein ansonsten
Temperaturen häufig um die zehn Grad
Marke morgen dann eben neue Schauer von
Nordwesten her ganz im Osten ist es
trocken hier zeigt sich die Sonne etwas
am sonnigsten noch im Südwesten und auch
an den Alpen gibt es Gewitter
Temperaturen erreichen höchste Werte von
17 bis 18 Grad im Nordwesten
Deutschlands gut zehn Grad mehr am
Oberrhein ansonsten Werte im Süden
durchaus um die 25 Grad ansonsten nach
Norden hin aber deutlich kühler die
nächsten Tage am Sonntag kommen neue
Schauer ins Land reingezogen im Sonnen
im Süden gibt es die Sonnenschein bei 18
bis 30 Grad ja und am Montag wird es
deutlich durchwachsener mit zahlreichen
Schauern und Gewittern bis 28 Grad und
Dienstag ebenfalls durchwachsen und dazu
sogar noch etwas kühler ein schöner
Abend